I had done a movie called The Children's
Hour with Audrey Hepburn and Shirley
MacLaine James Garner and I believe all
thanks
I believe that Alfred Hitchcock had seen
this movie because he requested meeting
me so I went over to his bungalow on the
lot of Universal and I went in and he
knew that I was born in Bristol England
and right off the bat he started telling
me great wines to get because that's
where his favorite wine cellar was and
I'm 12 and I'm studying there okay
I I wish I had written some of these
names down I they're probably excellent
he proceeded to tell me how to cook a
steak because at some point I would be
getting married and I would need to know
these things I never felt intimidated by
him I felt that I could ask questions
and he was always there to answer them
for me he would tell dirty jokes and I
had no idea but my aunt actually said to
me because she used to take me down to
the set she goes oh yes I remember you
came home one day you came home one day
and you said what is it that women do
that starts with a pea and my mom and my
aunt are looking at me like I said well
is something that women do and it starts
with the P and and they came up with
prostitution that's it that's what it is
well there's this nun and she goes to
the head of the convent and she says to
her I am leaving the nunnery I'm going
to become a prostitute and and the nun
says what she says yes I'm going to
become a prostitute she goes off for a
minute I thought you said you wanted to
be a Protestant what I found was so
fascinating is he shot everything twice
we shot everything in Bodega Bay and
Santa Rosa and then he like pulled up
the house and pulled up that gigantic
tree in
stuck it onto a universal lawton then we
reshot stuff and running down the hill
in Bodega Bay and then being on the
treadmill with these marionettes flying
down and the sand dunes were brought in
I mean it was like he there was some
sort of element that makes it when
you're watching the movie it sort of
adds a different dimension to what
you're watching and I think he he had
obviously visions of that I celebrated
my 13th birthday on the set tip he gave
me a set of love words which I had for
years Jesse gave me a sweater and then
Alfred drew me he wrote to the woman I
love Veronica and he drew his face and
then signed it and I have that framed in
archival paper and then when I got home
there was this huge bouquet of lilacs
and French tulips it was as big as me I
have a picture of me standing next to it
it was this giant yeah I mean it was
like wow I didn't even know terrific
there was a big surprise party I have a
picture of me with the entire cast and
crew and I'm bawling my eyes out which I
think I'm totally shocked and I think it
was that day that we had done the thing
with the chimney where all those birds
are coming down the chimney so yeah that
was quite a way to celebrate my birthday